[Musik]
wie im gestrigen blog gesehen habe waren
wir jetzt einen abend auch noch kurz im
bootshaus also ich habe nicht getrunken
und so was alles also ich bin ich
einigermaßen fit und es ist so greife
sweat die sonne leuchtet mit direkt in
die fresse machen also ich mach mich
treibt mich danach mit einem punkt gibt
euch einfach mal diesen unglaublich
kranken hier würde ich alles planung ist
das macht eigentlich wirklich sein
müsste mir übrigens echt noch mal so ein
paar format überlegen die ich so im
block einbauen kann zb can heißt das so
gemacht wenn ein blog sicher nichts
spannendes passiert ist irgendwie noch
auch zuschauer waren eingegangen oder so
dass wenn die ideen haben schreibt das
gerne mit nico mit klopapier mir es ist
so krank heiß alter wie viele discs hat
gerade babys ein
ja das kann hinkommen
hätte nicht gedacht dass ich treffe das
leben gut da ja man sonne ballack
ok tschüss leute das haus da oben die
hälfte fehlt einfach das jetzt noch mal
der rentenalter auffangen
wie fühlst du dich jetzt dass die
gleiche würde wie kommt man muss sich
das mal mitten auf der straße steht wenn
man sowas
wir sind zwar straße und gehen eis essen
mit selbe und luca leute das hier ist
standard
es werde überlegt kontraproduktiv
ich bin der 1000 die klausel sei nicht
einfach das zu vergessen
billiges köln dschingis kahn str
wir haben hier bei einer hand dies war
die chef gar nicht stimmt und ich habe
hast du lust darauf kommt dazu
die kann auf jeden fall gibt pfötchen
gibt pfötchen dummer hund also ja fatal
ihr seid so schnell los immer weiter
hinter merkel habe leben wir sind jetzt
hier in köln ging zum einen war strand
wird er war angekommen und wollen jetzt
ein paar instagram bilder machen aber
ich würde mich noch mal im kreis
schreibkraft
das foto gemacht wir wissen nicht wer
diese person hinnehmen
und deswegen ist wirklich eboli die
frist schon wieder steigen
ein neues 90minuten.at
[Musik]
juli fängt jetzt leckerli okay wir noch
mal kurz kaka mit dem also ich muss dir
nicht viel spaß
die leute wichtig ist doch nicht hin
müsse natürlich meine freundin noch mal
an jetzt macht es falsch findest du also
leute gehen unterstützung
dann fahre ich da ein mindestmass an der
munich sprachbedienung oder scheine
jetzt nicht hörst dann wirklich nicht zu
blitzer teppich gibt jetzt die leine du
machst das ganze ja mit dem brocken
[Musik]
während wir in rhede laufen kannst du
trotzdem blog übernehmen danke dir
wir haben jetzt gerade hier was gegessen
und werden uns jetzt auf den weg machen
zu einer freundin und dort noch ein
bisschen was dringend auf die klappe es
ist der baum muss einen vormarsch der
den bambus zu getötet hat denkt man so
sagen dass jetzt wieder die nächsten
szenen nur mit myphone gefilmt zu haben
weil ich die kamera einfach nicht
gebrauchen
[Musik]
wer bist du so was machst du das hat mir
schon mal bitte
das hat er gesagt was laufen ich wüsste
nicht was der plan ist jetzt gerade dass
wir zur em zu fahren weil debatten in 24
stunden spiel was ich jetzt hier haben
wir dich aufgeweckte junge weil ich es
schon verlangen zu verlieren
perfekt und so luft bei die folgen
morgens selber vier beaufort alles steht
in der rauen wir gerade schon gesehen
habe waren wir gerade noch bei rewe in
seinem leistung in hochform staat aber
wenn euch dieser blog ist nie gefallen
hat das gerne so ein leichter und sonst
würde ich sagen meine damen und herren
sehen wir uns morgen in dem video wieder
zu
[Musik]